[Music]
[Music]
hey my god gkg
what's up clapped up monster midnight
hello hello hello hello everybody i'm
sorry i'm a little late
i am not at my house tonight
so it was a little hard setting
everything up
i hope everybody hear me all right i
haven't worked on my phone
woof what's up
[Music]
sorry guys i'm not at my house tonight
i'm traveling right now
so
[Music]
i have like my portable setup with my
portable crappy camera my portable
crappy lights
hello christopher that's a heat
we have two minutes until we get actual
answers
for the show
from australia huh anyone from australia
well we have one minute guys i'm so
excited because we're finally going to
get some answers
oh what all are they going to tell us
are they going to tell us like who the
villain is like who's responsible
who's behind it they're going to tell us
that like i don't know
what are they going to tell us you know
like geez
well if you have disney plus open and
you're ready to watch it we have about
30 seconds
until we're gonna watch it soon
so let's see i don't know why my
thumbnail didn't save
all right that's 2 am
who's got their finger on the play
button
here we go we're going to start episode
four it
is 35 minutes we're gonna start in three
two one and
go i've hit play
i'm not going to be able to show the uh
previously in one division
two healthy baby boys
she came here because we're all what
all right so they're doing a recap of
what started what happened last time
all right intro
here's the intro
what is happening
what the heck is happening
whoa
oh she's coming back from the snap
whoa
so monica rambo was snapped
that's insane it's cool how this is
so it's like they fell asleep the people
who got snapped it's like they fell
asleep and just came back
so her mom died
murray rambo died her mom
so this is that five year gap
i actually don't need this mic
after you snapped after you disappeared
is what they called it
oh that's the classic marvel music
here we go all right man so she was
snapped
and her mother died during that five
year gap that she was snapped
maria rambo died her daughter
monica is now
going to be spectrum the hero and who
we've seen uh
throughout the time wow this started
crazy she was snapped and she came back
and they showed it they showed like a
bunch of people coming back
that's insane
that's insane man sword headquarters
sentient weapon observation response
division
the blip brings back loved ones
okay so she already worked for a sword
uh
under clearance is taken away
captain monica rambo
wow
this is pretty crazy um i'm on
i'm not home right now so i'm not in my
normal place
astronaut training program
they've been focusing on nanotech and ai
i betcha ultron's coming back
so she was an astronaut hmm
uh her mom started sword
jesus is crazy already man
you're grounded
terrestrial missions only that's pretty
good
wow
thank you irvine pb
so she so monica just got a new
assignment
her mom is the one who started sword she
works for a sword but her mom died
during the blip
because monica got blipped or snapped
and now she's back
and now she's going to new jersey which
i'm assuming is where she had the
assignment
west view
it started right now i am seven minutes
and 13 seconds into it
all right so she's at the energy jimmy
woo
he did a magic trick
that scott lang taught him
weird
new wrinkle um it's 35 minutes long this
episode's 45 minutes 35 minutes long
it is out guys i'm watching it right
here
so yeah it's out
[Music]
this is crazy already
so
uh i watch designer and super super
actually so i like them
all right she's opening a case it's
going to be one of those hazmat suits i
bet oh no it's not
oh it's like a drone helicopter okay
so she's gonna fly this sword drone
helicopter
into the shield
hey noah eg thanks for the donut
it is great so far all right she's
sending the helicopter
and it's pretty crazy noah i love it so
far
and she's flying yeah
oh so they don't even know the yeah this
is the scene that we saw this morning
she's about to put her hand through the
the force fields the scene that we
was released this morning by marvel it's
a force field
energy field
[Music]
careful rambo
all they're showing right now is the
episode is the clip from this morning
oh she got sucked in
so she put her hand in the force field
and she straight up got sucked into the
town
and now you can't see her anymore holy
crap okay
that's interesting all right 24 hours
later
looks like they have shield brigade
darcy
nuclear biology artificial intelligence
astrophysics
same old darcy
i didn't think she got sucked in i
thought she just like went in
and like got trapped when she went in i
didn't think it actually like pulled her
in because it actually like pulled her
in
darcy lewis she is dr lewis now
hmm
[Music]
mm-hmm
darcy is doing her thing woof haley
hubbard
cosmic microwave background radiation
i like that darcy has a role in this
it's actually really good
oh
okay so there's this like the beekeeper
suits
i knew it i freaking called it
i won't say many spoilers guys but i
freaking called it
i called it in my first breakdown video
of wanda vision
episode one and two
this
jimmy wu
that's darcy
he's dead right
what the heck
guys please stop spamming the chat
that was so confusing i don't even
i'm gonna have to watch this five times
ah i see
okay okay okay i see what's happening
played by huh
whoa
i like this this is really cool
cast ass that's pretty funny
whoa she recognizes somebody oh there
she is
with whom or else what
what
these people don't know any more than we
know
aaron two minutes ago
oh
interesting
so that means
so that means the helicopter wasn't
interesting
what the heck they're about to try to
communicate through want to be the radio
wanda who's doing this to you
wanda
so
what was weird
oh
i think i get one part i think i'm
slowly starting to understand what's
happening
here's the beekeeper
ah
interesting
yeah he's gone is that a jump rope it is
a jump rope
it's an old school jump rope hey it's on
my car what's up
no show us what happened
so we watched the beekeeper go under a
sewer
and go up and then wanda said no but we
saw it from the beekeepers perspective
but we didn't see what happened
they like cut it
that's darcy and detective wu talking
watching through the tvs
wanda giving birth
so you better hurry up and give me more
answers before this episode's over
so darcy's basically watching it like an
actual
tv show
another ultron reference
oh
she's about to get kicked she's about to
kick
monica and boa oh and then it cut
someone is censoring the broadcast
hydra it's hydra i understand what's
happening now
wow that was intense
oh this is intense who
are you one is about to throw monochrome
out
oh you're not my neighbor you're
definitely not my friend
oh
wanda just threw her out of the reality
oh my gosh this is insanely
oh my and the way she did it whoa
holy crap that's a little insane
that's amazing
all right so want to kick your ld now
and we saw it
and now she please don't end if you in
this episode would be so pissed
oh
fish is dead she's seeing him as like a
zombie now
okay he's back to normal
whoa
it wasn't a jump scare i mean i guess it
was i'll show you guys in a second the
episode's gonna be over in like six
minutes
she just said
i don't think that's true though
oh come on i still have i have like so
many more questions now
but they okay they answered questions
they answered
they answered a lot of questions for me
okay spoiler alert
avert your eyes for like 30 seconds
while i
show you guys some weird stuff
okay
avert your uh if you don't want to see
sports literally turn around
right now i'm going to show you
something you ready if you don't want to
see spoilers
here's this coming hold on i got to look
at the screen better this is what they
showed
where that dead vision
that's insane
all right hold up let's get uh let's now
go
chat with the guys one second
that is literally insane oh my gosh
that is
oh that's so insane
oh my gosh that was insane all right
let's get in our zoom meeting
really you're gonna update zoom come on
that was that was a pretty good one
so there's a few things happening
there's a few things happening
that i kind of get now
but also at the same time
interesting
i explain okay so clearly hydra
is in hydra is involved that's very very
evident
um very very very very evident
okay dude can you
frickin not
all right what's this code
all right hydra's involved and any time
i'll explain in just a second let me get
you're using that camera
okay something weird's happening hold on
i'm trying to get in with uh
it's gonna tonight is gonna be rob from
comics explained
it's gonna be brad lambert soups of
course
i don't know what else is gonna be with
us tonight but we're gonna figure it out
right now
oh i don't hear anybody
i heard i saw that you can hear me hold
on
holy crap wow wow wow
guys what an
episode man i mean that was yeah
that was pretty
first of all they mentioned dude they
mentioned chaos magic for the first time
in the mcu basically
talking about you know the cosmic
radiation that ties back to the big bang
yeah yeah
wow like that's chaos magic right there
you know what i'm saying this is insane
dude holy cow okay so guys we got a ton
to break down
first of all what was your reaction
when you just you started to see monica
form at the beginning of that episode
oh yeah that was really happening here
man dude i was like
i didn't catch on for like the first two
seconds i was like
did she get kicked out of the reality
and like particles but then i
was like oh she's coming back
yeah because we're all thinking like all
right all right so monica like she just
got kicked out of the reality we're
picking up with monica right
now
and what i thought was interesting is
they didn't know
wanda was in there until they pulled out
the broadcast
yeah yeah they just it was just a
missing person's report
yeah so
okay so there's clearly a
bail put over people that makes money
right yeah um
how we got like so many like different
like flashback scenes just like filling
in
little holes here and there we obviously
got that beat keeper scene
yeah just how we predicted sword agent
in a hazmat suit again things change in
this alternate reality
yeah and we have it's
it's you know it's funny there are so
many theories
about uh the beekeeper
who the beekeeper was and like
everything like that and it turns out
it's just you know
sword engine i mean i guess we kind of
knew that right because of the sword
logo on the back
yeah um but yeah that was crazy
but this this really showed that wanda
is completely her rocker she's
she's just completely lost it yeah so
now
now my original thought of her literally
killing the entire town
is like i would not be surprised at this
point now i'll uh 100
would be surprised yeah man and like
she hasn't even gotten to that place yet
because even when we saw that scene
where she kicked out monica
we saw that she immediately had like
hesitation regret like we saw that in
her face
and then she just played along when
vision walked in
but at some point we're gonna see one
that gets to the point where she doesn't
even care anymore
she doesn't even have any hesitation or
regret because guess what
like she said in this episode this is
her home
yeah oh man bro
hey grayson thank you so much for the
dono
so okay okay so so
so it's wanda but it's also hydra
i think that was made i think that was
made clear every time
because okay we have the commercials
that come in right because
if i'm not mistaken one time
they were like they were trying to
communicate that's the hydro commercial
came on
and then at the end she was like
something keeps interrupting and
it's i mean it could be like so hold on
i i took that when monica flew out
she all she kept saying was it's wanda
it's
just wanda so that told me
that wanda was in control of the cuts
once again it's her reality she's in
charge if you're not with that you're
out right
so when she cut vision off a few
episodes ago
and made him restart and do his take
again
yeah that one she liked right so she cut
that this is her
her world and you're just living in it
right so if you don't follow the rules
you're out like
uh uh monica yeah yeah i agree with you
yeah
yeah that's a good theory but i i truly
believe
now after watching this that it's 100
or at least at least mostly wanda let's
put it that way
i yeah and so perhaps the whole reason
for the hydra thing is like just related
to her past
right so but another thing too man is
that
again we know that water doesn't have
full control
and sword doesn't know anything about
mephisto
and agnes so like again in the
in the first three episodes that we saw
them watch in this episode
you know we saw some things going on
differently like with the spaz moments
like when
jimmy was contacting walden like what if
what if it was like mephisto that kind
of cut off the broadcast
so they don't see that wonders noticing
well right
and and if you consider that with the
part where she like cut herself and it
was like
that really weird scene with like their
super red blood and like that was
actually in color
and nothing else was in color right
wow yeah that was uh honestly i'm
surprised
i expected uh like half the episode to
be this
yeah and the other half to be the 80s
episode
um but i guess yeah i guess we're
getting that
next week look i guess 80s is next week
and then yeah episode 6 is halloween
yeah which means
which makes sense because the last three
episodes are just going to be
crazy yeah yeah that's crazy hey food
blogger what's up man
thanks for the donut we talking on
instagram is that
dude i completely like with just lot of
the way this episode
started dude i was like all right and
fury's gonna show up man we're gonna see
yeah yeah yeah so i love how they just
like
[Music]
threw sword at us right no no real i
think they did give us a little bit of
background right so
uh maria monica's mother started sword
which makes sense right because of her
captain marvel and her relationship with
scrolls
um but again she had a relationship with
nick fury so
i also like the captain marvel easter
egg right at the beginning where you
heard carol
in her head say that iconic line from
captain marvel
yeah that was great dude dude another
thing too man is that
again we've seen from you know the
promos that they've been putting out
lately
that one shot of monica and like a
fighter pilot
yeah it was like ship area we a lot of
us thought that that was gonna be
monika entering this ultimate reality
right right
but that's obviously not the case and we
still haven't seen that and we're going
to see that moving forward
which again just sets things up for
later on in the show
yeah another twist was uh
okay wait hold on it's fire thank you
for the donation did you notice how
things from her reality
came into the real world like the
clothes and the yeah
that definitely does mean that kind of a
house of m situation where
if you you create this fake reality but
if you bring it into the real reality
it's
real because the clothes were real like
you said
hey jay showtime thank you for the
donation yeah they had nothing on agnes
i don't we barely saw her in the tv
that time again but that just said
dude we haven't seen we barely saw her
in the last episode we did it
on this episode like they're setting her
up
big moving forward man so so so then
okay
so us having so us now knowing
that it's wanda how did that last
conversation take place with agnes
and i forget his name um herb
uh when they're like because we're all i
don't think they're dead anymore right
because they're talking about people
kind of going missing and people can
clearly go into this reality
but but what do they know what's herb's
role because i think agnes is pretty
i think i know what agnes rubble is
she's like with the hardness right i
think
mephisto and the grim reaper i think
like they're all working together
um but but how did they have that
conversation last night
so what does that mean now we're all
what
is it still trapped it's just trapped
in bed well talk about that dead vision
freaking holy crap that freaked me out
yeah oh dude and i was like
i immediately thought of the scrap poles
credit scene right where she
opens up you know the body bag and finds
visions dead body
yeah dude i think that's exactly what
went down i think
and that's how she snapped like right
she's like everything just happened
after avengers in-game
and then that scrap post credit scene
where she finds like seizes like dead
body
and then she loses it and that's where
we are now
by the way i still think we will i i
think that's why they scrapped it
is because they were going to show it to
us in one division
and now i think that's how you know what
what i actually think is happening is
they're going to somehow figure out like
they'll probably talk to fury is
actually what's going to happen
like what did wanda do after end game
after everybody got snapped back was she
part of the but what happened
and it's gonna say yeah she came back
and she helped fight this and blah blah
blah and then she went and saw vision
and this is what happened maybe
fury's in there we haven't seen him yet
right and
i think the next step is gonna be
structured kind of like the opposite of
this episode
where it's gonna be like primarily you
know 80s alternate reality inside there
and then on the swords end we're going
to see monica arriving
next episode where they you know since
monica's back and she understands
what's really going on here they're
going to go to the higher ups
we're going to see fury next episode
you would have to think now that monica
is back
they'll contact fury but also let the
avengers know that
freaking wanda is doing all of this
right right you know like because once
again like i don't know if they knew
plus so wanda came back in end game
fought the battle they all went to
stark's
funeral right right right so they had to
come back after that and she had to have
had her mental episode
but once again the avengers compound is
in
jersey it's right around that area right
yeah they're not too far
from this little town so it's not
far-fetched that she went from the
what was left to this small town
had a mental breakdown maybe took the
body of vision with her and literally
just crafted her own world in this small
town and claimed it as her own
yeah maybe she was like she took the
body and she was like driving away with
it or something and then you know
going through jersey to wherever that's
when it happened
um real fast let me address this irma
guard thank you for the donation
does the super high cosmic background
radiation mean she created the universe
no i don't think she created the
universe i think that's a
uh kind of like an easter egg towards
chaos magic yeah
she definitely created the reality 100
to the same energy that created the big
bang yeah
that says a lot man like that that's
that type of energy that'll rip hold
rip open to hold the multiverse kind of
thing you know
hail hydra marcos here on uh yeah what
what do we think
what did we okay i guess the hydra
are just kind of call call backs huh
yeah and hey guys if i i just went
through and looked at my donations if i
missed one i i deeply apologize
appreciate you homie um
it gave us answers it did give us
answers
the first thing i was like well freaking
sword doesn't know any more than i know
right now like you know what i mean i
was like they're doing the same thing
i'm doing they're dissecting footage
that they got i got the same footage
they got right now
i'm like this is interesting guys
so uh in the chat i'm seeing that
they're saying you know furious
a scroll yeah right so he's talos so
which one
like who knows what like does sword
actually know
that fury is talos and
right
i don't know you know because that would
be interesting too
um let's do it danielle
is not going to know what to do but
taylor also has a relationship
with me with i mean with monica
he has a relationship with bonnie right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't i don't see how he doesn't come
in yeah
it's just there's too many connections
uh daniel thanks for donato yes the
people in the town are real
um i i think and luke thank you for the
donut and i was about to actually say
that
i think this is how kind of strange
comes in right
because when you're dealing with
something that's weird and it's magic
yeah
and you're in your fury or your tallow
spirit
you know or your monika and you've dealt
with like superheroes
who do you call especially after in-game
right
yeah you call strange yeah that would
that would make
that would make the most sense so maybe
we get strange
in the next episode i mean that would be
the very next step
if sword finds out that wanda has lost
control and she's doing all this
he call the next best next strongest
most understanding person for this
which would be strange yeah and you know
because
fury's entrance is inevitable at this
point yeah
all of us understand that once fury
knows about this he's gonna alert
other avengers he's gonna he's gonna
bring more people into this
whole crazy situation so that's why it
makes sense for
maybe us to smoke in this for us to see
hawkeye yeah because guess what
for something as big as this when they
tell fury that we're dealing with energy
that created the big bang fury's going
to understand that
and say all right they ain't we're not
playing games here
let's call in the big guns i want to see
we see captain marvel
in this i agree yeah it would make sense
and brad you were talking about that
last time
yeah um we've never seen
fury interact with
strangers
pick up the phone and call strange what
if strange just senses and and
feels this dark magic and and goes
himself
you know maybe he's already gay yeah
yeah like
when i mean that reality was created he
could have just literally
opened the portal and walked to like
when it happened it really
happened something happened aka
right yeah oh well here here's the
here's an awesome coalition here devigar
sabavathi thank you for the donation he
says cosmic radiation equals fantastic
four which we know are coming
i i do think that's a great segue to
to them coming i i really really do um i
dig it
and it's like you just said how how easy
is it
for strange to you know because i always
think back
to what he said in infinity war
where tony's like you know what what do
you do what is your job and he's like
protecting your reality
douchebag
[Laughter]
uh yeah i do think there will be a boy
born that can swim faster than a shark
alfred yes i do thank you for the
donation
dude for sure by the way guys how great
was darcy man
i loved seeing her in it it was so good
it's just like it feels like she never
left you know i forgot the actress who
plays darcy but she just
completely owns that role and yeah
he did the card trick like
that was so good i was like scott lang
taught you that well
scotland inspired that that was so cool
yeah that was um
they're they marvel's so good at doing
those little things you know like just
those tiny little things
when the episode started and it didn't
start with the freaking marvel
you know intro i was like oh [ __ ] here
we go
[Music]
yeah man it just started and then you
know coming off of end game and then
they play the marble intro and then it's
like all right we're in for a ride
um
yeah it's gonna be the last one it's
gonna be a mandalorian right it's gonna
be the very last episodes where they're
gonna set it up
there's a lot i think they can do with
that
that cosmic radiation part they
mentioned in the beginning
i mean that could be the fantastic four
the eternals
chaos magic uh that could be so much
you know um yo what the yo it said
in the credits people are saying that in
the credits they mentioned tim roth
do they have a time stamp on that i
didn't watch the credits because i
figured it was i like skimmed through it
i figured it was like the same thing
okay no
yeah i don't think no i don't think so
where like how how what what was the
reference
i mean we know i mean it's confirmed
that he's coming back well
it's confirmed that uh i don't know if
you guys can give us some
time yeah it's confirmed that
abomination
yeah they confirmed that i don't know i
don't know if they said temperature is
going to play him but
they definitely said abomination oh he
did okay
okay so there was a part i want to see
uh guys i'll be right back i'm gonna use
the rest real quick
i wanna there was a now i have 166
people watching mephisto's confirmed
that's it it's
100 um
there was a part where they're like
looking at
um the boards and stuff
i want to know what he wrote on there
there has to be some
easter egg or clue on you know what i'm
talking about brad like
yeah yeah there has to be something on
there somewhere
yeah it's just really interesting just
uh
everything that went down in this
episode how they started the background
on monica i think was fantastic how she
lost her mother
and didn't know it yeah during the blip
that was
just devastating you know detail but
just so good for character development i
love it
um for sure dude i i can't say enough
about it just marble man oh they're so
good
and this this is like a lot of people
were like oh
you know screw one division i can't wait
for you know the falcon and the winter
soldier
right and like this is just showing us
what we're gonna get with all these
series
for sure get you excited oh just just
the inner connectivity
i don't know what to tell you i know i i
don't
it's insanely exciting and sorry let me
i wanna
i wanna acknowledge these donations real
quick sean webb thank you the hexagon
represents the storm on saturn
saturn represents a devil and underworld
which means mephisto shape of hexagon
dank that's that's pretty deep i like
that um
why can't i get away from this what's
crazy is that like all these
connections and cameos that are gonna be
made it's not
it's not even forced it's just like it
makes so much sense
yeah oh yeah that's like maybe the actor
paul is excited to work with uh
sam jackson fisto span
oh yeah winter soldier thanks for denno
yeah um so
so there was a i'm looking at
let me figure out what it is it's uh at
1747
um you can kind of see the board
and it says scrolls question mark it
says
behind this and then underneath it says
scrolls question mark so they
i mean i guess they know now right it's
wanda because she comes out and says it
but it does say triangulated to west
view five mile radius and the
they what we don't know why hexagons
shape so do but do we
do we still think aim it is
something behind it and yes uh
benji's dad online business coach thank
you for the nation yes betany did talk
about that post-credits scene
which we were talking about we think
wanda did see vision's body
and that caused her to kind of go crazy
and and create this bubble reality
that's what we're thinking happened
but uh yeah if we if you go to 1747
why the hexagon shape you know we i
think we've all kind of attributed that
to aim by now
um they've also asked you know is it
alive
jimmy jimmy wrote that on the board
which i thought was interesting
so they they don't know they know he's
dead but they're not
positive if he's alive yeah
when people pass the energy field do
they change
which was interesting you guys know how
like at the beginning of the episode we
saw like monica walking into sword hq
and we saw them building like spaceships
almost yeah
what if that's the spaceships where the
fantastic four go to space maybe
that would be pretty cool um
when the people pass the energy bro did
they change
i still think that you know they were
talking about the fantastic four's
origin being more in the quantum realm
right yeah yeah and that makes a lot of
sense to me
and that's another way to kind of tie
jimmy wound to it because he worked with
that man
um louis romo thanks for the donation i
do think
so when people when people pass through
this energy field i do think they forget
it i think they forget things and yeah
everything changes like their clothes
and stuff like that
um the beekeepers close but when they
come out they keep those clothes
which i think is the more interesting
part yeah it's part of what it is
right so is this a hex
that she has casted or is this a
mental breakdown that is somehow
like happened upon itself right like she
she could she didn't really control it
it just went boom
right yeah i think
i think it's more of that man i think
it's just more like just like her pure
energy
again we know there's other forces that
play with agnes and mephisto
so maybe they helped shape that and we
just didn't see it
and maybe that's how they introduced the
whole like agnes mentoring wonder kind
of thing like her maybe teaching wanda
how to make this
exactly how she wants this yeah but um
yeah
yeah i think it was more just like
mental breakdown she saw vision's body
emotional
boom almost like in the way the big bang
bang was created
she just boom kind of like exploded in a
way and created all of this
so the food blog's kitchen thanks again
for the donation
i think one is force field is what
unlocks the mutant powers in other
people
notice how the bees didn't come until
after they passed through the field
and then we know monica becomes spectrum
i i think yes i don't
know
i think it does for people who have a
mutant x gene
that that's what i think because
yeah oh oh oh oh oh a lot of people are
telling me that
there's a qr code at 1603 i'm gonna try
to get it i see
it now
oh my god 1603 come on
let's not get that come on guys
i want oh it see it
i can't i can't get it my phone won't
pick it up
someone get it
no yo this is real life and you can pull
that and see what it says
someone
how did you get it did you zoom in phone
got it
but it's yeah yeah yeah it just says it
says locked
bro marvel's blocking us from all this
and locking secrets
it's just so clever in this whole
freaking show joe reed thanks for the
donor car plate says zb718
zombies maybe not sure that would play
into the whole everybody's
dead thing you know
i mean
dude this is wild bro
what the heck i can't get the qr code
and it's making me mad
well it's going gonna be
uh marvel's gonna do something with that
right i mean
yeah uh go to 2701.
wait wait wait wait wait give me the
give me the bar code
2701 vision has an evil face at the last
second
yeah division kind of gave wanda a look
at the end like he was like kind of
suspect
yeah sure so let's talk about that too
because there was that one line where he
was like
we can leave and she was like no we
can't
wait 2701 when he's dead yeah
dude yeah that's so creepy holy crap
that
is sauce the beekeeper is fishing
the the the beekeeper is agent x
mitchell stiper thanks for the donation
the beat the beekeeper is agent x
oh my god one's horrified because also
also
what okay here's an interesting theory
so what since vision's dead
right what if vision is
the good wanda
so i was kind of thinking that too like
something something along that line like
it
it's her good consciousness her good
part of herself that's
left because that would be her like
what's going on this is weird
she's like having an internal battle
with herself
and vision is the embodiment of that
and that's why she is like controlling
you know and maybe maybe that part
when vision appears and it's like
he's dead that one part that's her
trying to say
he's dead wake up you know what i mean
like yeah yeah but also like you just
said
you know we can leave right right
and then her being like no no no this
is our home now and then this goes back
to like what this show's all about which
is wanda's mental health
this is the visual representation of an
internal conflict hundred percent
realize on the big screen
i think that might be what it is i think
we're on i think i think
and again we've seen we've seen it
multiple times in just his personality
like oh my gosh dude
like this isn't vision the vision we
know and love
this isn't the vision we know and love
we've seen it not just in his powers
it's definitely not him
and his personality yeah so
it's definitely not him but going back
to what
one of um someone in my chat said he
donated
when things exit the reality they stayed
the same
yep so
so here's my question what
all the people we know now are real
they're they're like tangible you know
what i mean
so is is is this
part of wanda controlling vision's dead
body is the dead body actually there
right that's my question is it tangible
or is it an illusion she's created
well that on on that note we've seen in
trailers once again we don't know if
this is just made to look that way for
the trailer
or it's actual footage right right we've
seen
uh scenes where the kitchen is like
destroyed
not like there was a battle but it's
like a
bomb or something went off and destroyed
the whole town
right but wanda like checks it so it's
back to normal back to her reality
so that leads me to believe that it
could be along the lines of
everybody's dead and she has just made
them into these
puppets for her perfect little life
that's so immortal
[Laughter]
man like imagine she took vision's body
after seeing it from the compound right
and she she went away and she's you know
driving away
and she just has a mental breakdown in
this small
neighborhood this town and just loses it
and kills the entire town and
in that explosion of emotion and just
not being able to control herself
she panics and creates this pocket
reality where everything's picture
perfect and not the nightmare that she's
created
yeah yeah
oh wait hold on at 25 47 you can see an
evil
face yeah that's like
his vision no it's
rambo being thrown out i don't think
i don't think that's an evil face i
think she's just in in
shock about what's happening talk about
how freaking cool that was
when like she used her powers
and she almost looked like i'm gonna
watch this part right now
after she did it she was like looking at
her hands right
like wow like maybe she used a different
type of power it didn't seem like it was
new
but maybe she also maybe she also kind
of forgets sometimes and
i think she does you know well once
again we talked about this in previous
conversations where
we have not seen the red aura the red
energy that makes for power which
does everything yet right right right
never seen that so far in this series
which was odd and i feel like that's
because wanda
aesthetically wants to make herself look
as comforting
and normal as possible right but
this was from monica's pob
yeah where she saw this scary one and
when she was looking at her hands man
yeah i think that was the good one
the good one of realizing oh [ __ ] like
that was the civil war wanda when she
blew up the embassy
right oh my god i can't believe i just
did that but then she snapped out of it
real quick and went back into the
possessed
insane out of her mind broken wanda
scarlet wish and then it was like no big
deal
well because when you have a perfect
reality you don't care you don't want to
give it up
and here's a good question and here's a
good question right here ryan vetter
thanks for the donut
if monica lost all her memory upon entry
how'd she remember that ultron killed
bithrow and where
did the beekeeper go since he
disappeared that was what i was actually
kind of
pissed about i'm like no show us what
happened to the beekeeper when she said
no
did nothing happen and just she reset
because we heard her say no
and when it was from her perspective
when she said no it was like
instantaneously
yeah it reset and she said no and he sat
there for a little bit after so maybe
just nothing happened to him
but that doesn't make any i don't know
yeah that was one of my biggest
questions like what happened to the
beekeeper
beekeeper when she said no yeah same
here we talked about last time like did
he
get kicked out of the reality did he
cease to exist
um i don't know
hey i keep coming back to division
that was from monica's pov right
yeah the dead body that walked in there
walked in the room man like that
that tells me that this is 100
fabricated oh my gosh and it's so clever
because once again
what we watched before was the the
uh broadband signals that she's putting
out for
people to watch right her dream reality
this is what i want it to be but when
you're in there
maybe it is different maybe you're
seeing something different
want to see what you want to see but you
may be seeing something
totally totally different yeah
people are also
and her potential involvement oh yeah i
i i would be surprised if we didn't see
her at some point
yeah and and like the the fury that
everyone thinks
is fury is talos and he's working with
maria hill coming up apart from home
so i wouldn't be surprised if we see
that door return and somebody made a
nice
uh comment in the chat about
remembering far from home where fury and
marie hill say that strange is
unavailable
oh oh yeah
there's no way they set that up that
early bro i mean there's no
yes they did it's marvel right
right there like just because the thing
is that this could be going on it's far
from home could be going on
simultaneously so like
yeah right because we don't know what
time thanks man
well that's what marvel does the best
and
going back to the whole maybe it is
there
there they see what they what their
perfect reality would be
yeah and maybe just like wanda sometimes
things get triggered right so
i think because i had a um a donation
that same one where they asked you know
what happens when um
like how do they kind of remember things
sometimes i think it's triggers
right just like kind of in your own mind
in real life
you know you you have certain triggers
that will activate certain memories so i
think
when wanda was like i was a twin monica
was like wait a second wait a second
i know who you are yeah yeah i know
you're it's a little foggy right
and then it's just kind of like kind of
comes back
uh yes thank you comic
chat for the uh donation episode four
did kind of
start to make sense but uh
shout out to us in the chat watching the
stream
[Music]
first i was like butt head switch to
movie
that's hilarious who's the missing
person jimmy's looking for though that's
a good question
matt hutch and thanks for the donut that
is a good question right
is it is it a is it a just a random
person right
yeah well let's think about this they
were in witness protection
remember they did say they did say it
was in witness protection in the
beginning so
yeah clearly might not be nobody
maybe it was i think they said it was a
guy right
maybe because maybe i was trying to like
look out for that to see like who
specifically they were looking for
yeah so i had the thought
that maybe
maybe as she's going through new jersey
maybe with vision said body because we
know about that
would have been post-credits scene maybe
that's when she runs into agatha and
agatha's the one who like sends her
overboard right
because because brad you made a good
point like we know the avengers facility
is in upstate new york
um not far from new jersey at all
so she's clearly she traveled some
distance i would assume she has vision's
body
because i think if you're gonna
i think if you're gonna give it to
anybody it's gonna be her because of the
connection but also you don't wanna say
no to her like
she'll make you do it once again she
doesn't need anybody's permission that's
what i'm saying like
you know yeah and maybe that's what
happened maybe she saw him and she was
like he's mine and they're like well we
need to take him and she's like no
and she like she could have blown up the
i mean the avengers facility was blown
up already
so she who knows what she could have
done man i mean
who knows where this uh this episode
like
episodic i don't know about the word but
you know where she started having this
episode
of like maybe like a mental breakdown
who knows where that started
yeah you know what i mean did you notice
that 718 who does the card trick that
scotland did
yeah that was such a fun it was so good
just it was so small but it meant so
much because we all just immediately
went
scott yeah i mean it was so
it was that was so good classic
gosh that was good speaking of scott
any chance we see this man scott in here
uh i don't know magic i don't know
man but that's just my personal opinion
yeah they're not online they're not up
there for me
you missed it earlier in the in the
pre-show um
i had a theory about hawkeye
um where you know
if juana goes missing one of the first
avengers that should be called is the
one that has the closest most powerful
relationship with her
right and it was vision he's dead so
you're gonna call hawkeye who's
basically her mentor
this entire time in the mcu right so
hawkeye shows up to try to save her but
in reality
he she loses her mind has an episode
freaks out
doesn't attack whatever and that's why
he loses his hearing
oh dang i
like that sets him up
to look for someone to take on the
mantle because he can't do this anymore
right
yeah well i really like that
that's probably it's almost too perfect
i would say that's a good chance that
happens in all honesty
because i thought about that too because
he because uh
she's with him at the end you know it's
just them two by the river so
i think that's a good chance uh hold on
real fast uh tommy santana thank you so
much for the donation what a vision is
mephisto
but he can't leave because wanda won't
allow it and his goals
ultimately cross over into our realm
hence why agnes is almost kind of
getting
her to open up yeah i i think
in um i think in some way shape or form
mephisto has a plan
to to try and take over
the earth realm i think that might be
his plan and i think that's
why he wants the kids yeah i think it's
all it all has to do with the kids
so again and the things that we haven't
even seen the kid plot play out
because in the first three episodes it
was all for the children
now the kids aren't here right we didn't
even get anything for the kids in this
episode
we weren't in the reality
yeah i mean we weren't in the reality
this time you know what i'm saying
so dan from pensacola thanks for donato
i was actually born in pensacola florida
so hey maybe you guys covered this but
where are we on the timeline
i think it is directly do we think it's
directly after the snap
i think it i think it is because well no
they said didn't they
it's three weeks after the snap yeah
yeah yeah
so is it though forum coming
or not home sorry apart from home the
rattlesnake venom thanks for joining
us that's what i'm saying so i think
it's before so if we do see nick fury
it's
not him or it is him and the reason that
he went into space for a little vacation
is because of the events of one division
oh i like that yeah philip gong
this is some people are saying in the
chat
ralph is the missing person
hey i think ralph is in the fist i think
and philip thanks for the donut he just
said agnes tells vision he's dead in the
trailers
she sees past one it's made of reality
her and mephista are tampering and
draining her powers in the tree
yeah i mean everyone's singing at 13 23
that's my fist though at
13 23. guys we don't know what what the
mcu version of mephisto looks like right
we have no idea
so like yeah you know i see some creepy
ass faces
in in this reading you know yeah yeah
that's people like reading
but you know it's just it's tough it
also resembles
it also resembles the grim reaper's
helmet right
right you know so that that's like i see
it now
cr1138 thanks for donate 3892 population
number pointed out why is that an easter
egg
uh off the top of my head i don't know
guys on the inside or not is that number
significant y'all
i i would have to deep down google for
that yeah
so but um
what if one that becomes evil when she
realizes that wicked and speed aren't
real
i think that's exactly what's going to
happen oh you're saying i mean for sure
we saw that we saw that almost happened
in this episode when bishop was just
like
let's leave and she was like no this is
our home and
she is she is willing to fight and die
to protect this reality
you know we're gonna see that come to
we're gonna see that heat up
moving forward so
what about when wanda told dottie i'm
sure you don't mean any harm and then
dottie said i don't believe you jonathan
harper thanks for the dono
brad what were you saying about her in
the beginning her supes was it like
i think dottie is a complete
misdirection i think she's a pawn for
agnes
you think so as well as mephisto because
i think mephisto still is
ultimately in control of this i think he
can go in and out of any character he
wants other than agnes
of course which is why i think he's
ralph
i think he he pops into dottie uh and
and kind of
you know pokes the bear if you will uh
which saying something like that to
wanda would definitely piss her off
um you know so i i think between agnes
and mephisto if this is the case i think
they are
pushing her down a path to a result that
they want
but also letting her roam free and live
her perfect little
life to a certain extent
dude so
uh 28.39 if you
pause it vision looks like mephisto and
it's
shout out kyrie for the donation freaky
as well
yeah vision again that's that's what's
up malek how's it going man
straight out of infinity war the robert
envy
could darcy be working for hydra the way
she brushed off the com
the commercial seam sketch now i don't
think so but thank you for the donation
um i don't think so i think that's
i think it's darcy being darcy yeah
um if she
is somehow working for hydra i think
it's because she would be brainwashed
somehow uh yeah not darcy's i don't i
don't
i think after everything she went
through with jane and thor right
because darcy helped save the world and
thor too you know
yeah not like warren we were talking
about a pre-show
that um that uh
potentially like i think it would make a
lot of sense if if we get like a jane
reference
and darcy mentions that train like
settle down or like
hey yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah she had to oh yeah she's not really
doing it anymore because she's sick
yeah yeah oh hey bluey 2010 thank you
for the donation do you think darth
strange will come in in the series
lead up to the movie addresses that her
reality bubble is going to be yes i do
and uh uh guys i wanted to backtrack
because
we know supes are brad i can't remember
who mentioned it
that said and far from home uh
he's like what about doc strange and
he's like you know so
we know that this now takes place before
far from home
so that's this has to be clearly what
he's
occupied with right because because yes
this does lead up to doctor strange and
yes i do think we're going to see it or
it's not necessarily
the uh the pocket reality itself
but the aftermath right the multiverse
collapsing
sure yeah i think that's
well that's crazy you know what and and
oh dang it marvel you're so good and
that's why nick
fury or talos believes mysterio when he
says i'm from a different reality
they're like well that makes sense all
the realities just collapsed
you know what i'm saying that's why it's
not that that's why it's not that big of
a deal to them because they're like well
yeah want to just collapse the whole
freaking multiverse
it makes sense that other people are
coming here dude i was just thinking
about that like you don't think
like that would have been more like
mainstreamed like we would have heard
about that apart from home if like
wanda ripped a hole throughout the
multiverse nah because they don't want
people to know
true uh it's a cover up right treb's all
thanks for don't know paul could be
excited work with benedict right
yeah i don't think he's that secret
surprise actor
that uh oh yeah that paul was talking
about what i i i think it's
i think it's like an older actor like a
classic older actor
that's gonna be mephisto that's that's
what i think it is i think it's gonna be
like
you know like dick van dyke red it's
obviously not
because clearly can't beat him but i
think it's going to be something like
that right
dude please
thanks for the dono at 1744 when they
mention the hexagons that is a map of
the town the energy field is
in the shape of a hexagon hey
1744 so
okay if we don't think
yeah yeah so if we don't think
if we don't think it's aim with the
hexagon then what somebody mentioned
before
about the whole saturn connection
connection to the devil thing could be
true
yeah and again the whole six corners six
six six oh yeah yeah well that's evaded
me this whole time
also the uh people keep talking about
visions look at the very end of the
episode where they both look into the
camera
uh vision does it very creepily i will
say that
it's not a normal kind of appearance
into the camera
he does it he looks at the camera first
before wanda uh this is at like this oh
my god
yeah what is 28 what is that face bro 28
15 mark
uh and watch how that plays out it's
very
creepy wait what are you sitting on the
couch
yeah oh yeah
so once again uh i i think that could be
mephisto
jumping in and out of the puppets in
this pocket reality
it also could be um
just a weird take yeah right um
but you know i do think you know it
could be interesting that
vision is good wanda the the good yeah
that's
i like that aspect or that theory the
best of wanda
right yeah eric thanks for donald wait
why can't ralph
be master pandemonium because he was
collecting the fragments of mephisto so
he can be
resurrected i mean he very well could be
um
i i think i don't think they're gonna
introduce master pandemonium i think if
anything it'll be like the grim
reaper doing it for mephisto since we
got that easter egg and that's why i
think so because we got that easter egg
jose marrero thanks for the donation
you're the man do you think wanda
is going to will most importantly her
kids but maybe vision as well back
to back into the real life or do you
think she'll lose everything
you know i do think she's gonna lose
everything
yeah and i think that's going to be an
even bigger tipping point
and i yeah you know um
now at the end will she have discovered
that she can create realities and kind
of bring things back to life
and use that maybe now i will say in the
comics
you know mephisto does take her kids
away but they're
reincarnated into other kids and she
eventually does reunite with them
so maybe there's something there they're
gonna do um yeah that's the thing
because like i don't that's that's
what's been tearing me apart is that
um you know we've heard them say that
wicked and speed are going to have a
future
in this right right have said that but
um
i just don't see like i see it so
clearly where she loses her kids and
then that's what really sends her over
the edge
i don't see anything else really sending
her well i'm just trying to think of
a way they could come back right um yeah
yeah that's that's the big question
and which again would bring me to the
if she has discovered
that she can create a reality and kind
of take
some body from one
and then bring it to the other and bring
it back to life
right so 1807 there's a note on the norm
and it looks like mephisto what
you're really looking for we're really
looking for
guys yeah i i sadly don't think they're
gonna
give it to us to like probably
episode nine in all honesty yeah i think
they're gonna start to say
at this point i feel like now we're just
like
looking for like every little thing like
someone mentioned like
someone mentioned that um at 2615
you can see like a giraffe decoration
and they were like
giraffe mephisto you know there's been
an animal in every episode draft
the draft well even in my chat right now
six six six subs and we're talking about
the devil thanks for the donut sun
stunt wizard flavy all right hear me out
bill jones is mephisto
thanks for the donut phil jones with the
mustache
with the mustache man um
well dude i'm just so ready for the post
credit scenes oh gosh
i know so
dang man i'm really like
i'm just really
so i don't think we're gonna see me
vista to like the eighth ninth episode
i think he's going to pop
up but we're
they're not going to say it's him like
us us people are going to think it's him
right but they're not going to say it's
him
it's going to be like vision being
possessed by something right
or something like that right you know or
agatha you know because i think they
mean
because eventually they're going to have
to reveal agatha is just
you know upon she's not
part of the reality at like everybody
else's
yeah she's there on her own accord
which is also an interesting theory
right so if
if you enter the reality like
monica did like the beekeeper did right
yeah
i think they are impacted differently
than the ones who were trapped there
from the beginning right because they
maybe the you know the the people who
were trapped in the beginning didn't go
to energy field
and right here bluey 2010 thanks for the
donor asking the same thing
you think monica gains her powers from
being from exposure to wanda blasting
her and
going through the force field yes i do
yeah yeah 100
yeah um activates the mutant gene
right activates immune gene so it's like
not gonna be for everybody but yeah brad
you might be right maybe when wanda
like explodes it's not like an outward
explosion but like just the barriers
goes down you know
yeah and like another thing too when it
comes to the homophysical situation like
at some point you know wanda and vision
are gonna be so s
and then when they try to go at agnes
she could easily just say something like
so you guys haven't met my husband
yeah i would love that well i think when
we see
my sister it will be a oh here is ralph
finally the reveal yeah and i think that
will be
very out in the open that he either has
the
iconic red skin or he just looks so
different from everybody else
no dude again it's like um it's like one
of those things where it's like
everything is black and white but he
comes out and he's just red exactly
that'd be super cool i i and i think you
might have hit the
nail on the head supes i think at one
point in time stuff's gonna go down
and it's just kept like what is all this
what is happening what is going on who
are you and she's just gonna be like
let me introduce you to my husband yeah
yeah
like why did you take my kids you know
like agatha agnes takes the kids or so
she's the one takes the kids right
something like that
and it's just like you know sergio barra
thanks for the donut the hexagons could
definitely just be the shape of wanda's
chaos hex magic emerging similar to dr
strange's magic
oh yeah like a uh is it called a ruin
i think like a rune that that around his
hands
it could be uh was it confirmed that um
i think his name is norm was the guy
from agents of shield
like that was his real identity
what are we talking about is it um one
of the people that was in
what that's that are in west view like a
ton of people are speculating he's the
same one of the agents from agents of
shield
and um they revealed like actual names
of people
so like i don't know if we ever got that
confirmed
i don't know thanks sergio for the
for that donation and 19. great put
18 19. look at agnes paige dude i want
to zoom into like agnes
yeah and then you have an agnes i tried
this morning
when that spot came out yeah um going
from
grayson thanks for the um donation going
from thanos to mephisto doesn't make
sense marvel's always eased us into
concepts
we may not see him and talk until dr
strange yeah i
i'd have to agree with that i that's why
i was saying like i don't know if we'll
see until the ninth episode
and even then they're not
i don't think they might not hey corey
robinson what's up
i don't think they i don't think they're
gonna just come out and say like this is
mufesto
i think it's just gonna be like this
crazy weird cribby villain that people
are gonna kind of think of the devil
right
and we're gonna know we're gonna know i
think it's gonna be like
an infinity war end game type of
situation where like at the end he just
comes in
and kicks ass and then
you know that's where wanda goes crazy
she loses it
and we're left on like a huge
cliffhanger going into spider-man 3 and
multiverse of madness
insane
um what an episode oh that's his name
the guy with the mustache his name is
sit right
is that his name
harold proctors jones who is that is
that anybody significant to marvel
i know phillip jones was significant but
um his real name i don't know i'm sure
one of these people's real names are
like extremely significant
fractals the head department of h's
youth accelerated division
dedicated to development what
again like they labeled everyone in that
reality like why isn't
dottie like why isn't her page there you
know what i'm saying
right wasn't her page there like at all
yeah
when her husband's is there right
because yeah the mustache guy is her
husband
wait so hold on because i'm looking at
like 1813 where it says
the guy with the mustache it says his
alias is sit a met
i don't know what that means harold
proctor
alias who is um i think this might
set up secret invasion but like why
would they kind of like
put scrolls in there like what like why
would they even question scrolls
right being behind all this right if
they didn't already know of like evil
scrolls being out there
do i think skye will come back from
agents of shield jacob downer thanks to
xeno no
i i don't
i don't think kevin feige wants to cross
over like the past television shows and
netflix shows and stuff like that
i think he's gonna reboot whatever he
does do so maybe in that way
but i mean best case scenario
i think that most will see is like maybe
see coulson come back
at some point yeah there's a rumor going
around right now
i also love how you know they kind of
viewed it as a tv show
and when they like figured out who
people was they're like oh this person
cast as this person it's like
like they were actually casted for the
show or something
yeah grayson thanks for the donut yeah
they did they did literally confirm it's
wanda
you don't think it's mephisto
i think they're fighting sword in the
trailer maybe like
trying not to get out of the reality
right emcee
names i think sword is gonna be you know
the bodies that wand is gonna be
dropping later on in the show
interesting at some point she's gonna
like go after agonists or something
yeah stunt wizard thanks for the
donation mcu fandom wiki
updated let's check that out
yeah everyone has an idea except for
agnes song it's going to be interesting
to see how sword talks about agnes
moving forward
right how they question her well because
at one point because she's
on the board they don't have an id for
her at one point
in time they're gonna be like who is
this
because she's gonna be really involved
with wanda
and they're just and there's no way
you're just gonna sit there and go
well who cares about this person that's
super close to
to wanda you know who's clearly
affecting her somehow
they're gonna try to figure out who she
is yeah like i feel like next episode
when we really see like the majority of
like the 80s
kind of like the 80s episode which is
next episode yeah um
they're like watching on the tv and
they're just like who's that
and then that's where we kind of get
swords perspective on
agnes and another thing too is that uh
uh that i noticed is that over the
course of monica's entire
time in that alternate reality she never
interacted with agnes not once
so she doesn't even know herself yeah
that's true
well wasn't she at the yeah yeah they
were at the
little tea party thing together and the
talent show but
yeah they didn't interact they were just
there
in the vicinity just in time thanks for
the donut appreciate it that creepy
smile at the end definitely need to
bring up more even the look by vision
you tell me doesn't know
definitely suspect yeah i mean he
definitely looked evil and we were
talking about that right i mean he
definitely looked evil and it definitely
looked like he looked into the camera i
don't know about vision bro
dude marvel's doing such a good job
it's like really not giving anything
away it's crazy
and vision is dead and it's just one of
creating him i wonder how he's able to
have thoughts emotions
of his own referring to him starting to
question what is happening if that makes
sense
yeah and even when wanda said like
i guess um like no like this is our home
we're staying here
yeah he gave her like he looked at her
in like a weird way you know what i'm
saying
it was definitely odd like that's the
thing that
vision is one of the big question marks
in all of this
like what's going on we got a ton of
answers this episode
but um vision is one of the big
questions moving forward
well i think it's memphis
excuse me i think it's mephisto
possessing him
wanda projecting herself
onto him or brad
that's another one of the big questions
we have is like how much of this is
mephisto and how much of it is wanda
because we know it's both of them at
some capacity i think it
boils down to
some i think something big that we need
to find out is
how did this start
i think it was wanda having a breakdown
but
was it agnes who like made her break
down
right did she meet someone in new jersey
that was agnes and she just kind of said
something to intentionally do it right
because right right because i think if
you're
mephisto and agnes and these people and
you
you're watching earth the earth realm
and you saw all this that just happened
with
thanos and infinity war and end game and
you see this extremely powerful
we'll say witch right scarlet witch and
you need to get something done
and you say well here's my opportunity
because this girl's not okay
you know what i'm saying so let's take
advantage of this
here's my wife or you know minion
partner whatever agatha may be to
mephisto in the mcu
let's go get this done go send her over
the edge
just thanks created she can kind of
control it but
i'm gonna control it too that's why you
could not get rid of that crane before
you know what i mean
like yo and um tyler h put
on 1822 on agnes page it says
ralph's status is unknown ooh
1822 yeah i'm gonna have to dissect this
stuff
yeah i have to like zoom in like ultra
zoom
because i really want to see what agnes
page consists of
oh check this out luigi thanks for this
dono
so you know how one division takes place
in new jersey well there's a story of a
creature there
called the jersey devil the story is
about a mother supposedly
a witch and he said continue to next
donation
i'll wait for that thank you interesting
though
again nothing here is unintentional no
reason this went down in jersey
ever and not upstate
well i mean yeah you have the new jersey
devils or hockey team
so there is i i can't remember that
story but now now i am lightly
recalling the jersey devil that it was
like a mother that was a witch
and i'll wait for his next donut i don't
remember what happened
but they could be that's another
connection
um sean put here shawn thank you for the
donation sean put
just thought i'd put it out there most
likely the cosmic background radiation
isn't some magic or anything it's just a
nod to tv history because
uh cosmic background radiation is the
cause of static on old tvs
um do you guys think that was like a
reference to like chaos magic and mc or
do you think it's just like
kind of like the energy of like static
of old tvs
um both
yeah i mean because the thing is that
they did say it's the same energy that
created the big bang
right so in the mcu it could be
something completely different than how
it is in the comics
hey jacob thanks for dono don't think
loki's gonna be in the show
sadly
jose thanks for the dono so she
basically dancing around
a dead body but it's projected in his
real vision
i don't know like they could lose start
next episode or the next episode after
that like
with wanda after end game like just the
way they started this episode yeah they
could
yeah that'd be sick i mean how how gutsy
or how crazy was it to just start this
episode coming off of the last one
like right in the middle of that game
yeah
ingenious again completely unexpecting
and that's the thing is that after next
episode or like even going into the next
episode
we're all expecting something we're all
expecting you know the 80s episode where
we see
agnes wanda we see more of the kids
and then maybe we see like we're
probably gonna see the aftermath of like
monica landing at swords base but they
could really start next episode
the way they started this episode off
event games
continuing to put together the pieces of
how this all that came to be
yeah now it's all good stuff honestly i
i can't
i can't wait to see um
what what direction they're taking but
uh this was not what i expected for the
fourth
episode fully um but i'm certainly not
upset about it but
i personally like how they're diving
into you know
the point where wanda's really cracking
under
the immense stress and trauma that she's
faced
right you know back even before we met
her uh in the mcu
so um you know uh i'm
on a twitter thread right now and
someone was like oh i'm pissed or going
through
or going to the she's crazy uh
you know woman dealing with the loss
kind of thing and i'm like no no no this
isn't
this isn't your typical right women
can't handle lost thing
this is a this is a traumatic
buildup yeah and and just anyone in
their right mind would crack
under all this loss and trauma um let
alone someone with these
oh yeah and then it's also about
you just said it right it's also about
probably the most powerful
person on earth going through it
yeah so grayson thanks for the dono you
don't think
mephisto's going to come until phase
five
maybe he's not in it at all but agnes
might be dropped in episode nine but
maybe not mephisto
maybe you know
i feel like it's just i i feel like
there's just too much that has said he's
gonna be
in this you know yeah i just i
the i just feel like there's too many
the devil's in the details right that's
not all
that's not you know that line and you
know i don't know
todd andrew thanks so much for for
supporting the channel donations
darcy coffee garcia deserves a coffee
darcy needs to come free
do do i do i think wanda is going to be
antagonist of
uh dark strange too yes yeah at some
capacity
some capacity eventually yes
yeah i think she's going uh down the
rabbit hole that's not a good one
but on that on that note boys i gotta
get out of here
uh well real quick real quick here's a
really good point
sean webb thanks for the dono you
understand vision can't
get her pregnant right so she
was either impregnated by the devil or
she was impregnated by the devil
or or she made herself pregnant yeah she
created the kids herself
yeah i i totally think so like herself
so yeah but all right
peace out homies i'll see you guys
appreciate y'all appreciate you
guys you guys next week see you guys bye
bye
sorry let me address some of these
donuts here i don't want to miss any of
them
let's just do this again
so
yeah i definitely think she either made
them herself and her perfect reality or
it was mephisto
it's probably the fake manner in front
of man three thanks for the donut caden
that's hilarious uh wait no i lost
uh
jacob thanks for doing i'm not sure i
understand what you mean it is
interesting how people
coming back from the blip wasn't all
good
um yeah i mean your state of mind from
coming back
something like that you know it's like
super weird right i mean
imagine if that happened to you i don't
really i don't really
i don't really know how you would react
to that in real life you know what i
mean
uh there was one that i wanted to
address
but it was i think it was
grayson who said you just don't think
it's gonna be right away yeah
but you know at the same time yeah
grayson
no not phase five just not day one face
four build up you know
i i kind of like agree with you but at
the same time
marvel's not gonna wanna do the same
exact thing they did before you know
what i mean like
they're they're not gonna they're gonna
switch it up
right and maybe that's hey instead of
taking 10 years to build up one villain
let's introduce them right away and have
them be a constant problem
but we know that like a ton of villains
are gonna be in phase four phase five
and all that
too big to give us day one phase four
they may go standard really into a
guardians they ease into it
yeah and and i agree with you but i also
think that if they did want to switch it
up
they'd have to they'd almost have to put
him in right away not not
have to but they could luigi thank you
so much for the donation
who birthed the child was turned into a
demonic being and the father was
apparently the devil himself sounds made
of some theories
oh all good but i do like that um
i'm gonna definitely look into that i
definitely think that's a link
because white jersey and marvel does
everything intentionally right like you
were saying
so jersey devil yeah i
i just you know grayson to your point
they might not
say it's him right away but i think it's
him
i think there's too many devil
coincidences and maybe it's because
we're looking for them right
we think it's him so look for it right
you think about a yellow car you see
yellow cars right you find what you're
looking for
um so far so far from takes place eight
months after in-game this is three weeks
wonder what happened in between
i think a lot of the multiverse popping
into pieces happens in between
i look like zuma's son thanks i uh i'm
not home right now
um i'm in arkansas helping my uncle
remodel a house so we can sell it
um so i brought like crappy camera
that's why the quality is not good
that's why i'm in this
room his little office and i brought
crappy lights so
that's why it's kind of poor quality
today so i'm sorry about that
yeah uh tj lewis i think we do see other
heroes
maybe hawkeye right maybe they do i
think at some point in time they have to
show us what happened
after end game and paul bettany who of
course plays vision
vision revealed that there was going to
be a post-credits scene
two avengers in-game that was wanda
finding vision's body
so
i don't know if this vision that we're
seeing is just like as dead body
like i don't like what is it
right
yeah grace and i agree i think the sixes
are
some people are we are stretching right
even i'll
say i'm guilty of it myself
daniel herring thanks for the donation
and i agree
west views on a real town wanted to took
it over she created it but then didn't
he say he was from west view
i think west view is a real town but his
member i don't know maybe not
because didn't the police officers say
you know
well she's in a real town she's like
where are you from he's like westview
jose thank you for the donation one is
the villain to some point and doctor
strange totally team up and bring one of
his kids to reality that's when she
studies herself
yeah it would make sense that doctor
strange is the one who brings them back
and brings her back right from from
i don't want to say evil i just want to
say like
she she is just she just doesn't care
anymore
and she just does what she wants abolish
thanks for the donation is this a dumb
theory do you think daddy is cleo
not a dumb theory in any way shape or
form i think that's a good theory
she very well could be she she clearly
doesn't seem to be a
normal person in that town especially
since sword didn't have
we didn't see a picture of her or i
can't remember if we didn't see a
picture we didn't see an id for her
no no it's not a bad theory at all and
you may actually be right
oh he said east view not westview
hmm maybe
yeah grayson um i'll look out for you
do my personal instagram cosmic warren
13.
i think i think that's what it is let's
let's check it out uh no just cosmic
warren
john montez thanks for the follow my guy
i've been watching a long time now never
seen a live stream discussion keep with
the great working content
you've done a great job with us keep us
on our toes
and uh interesting anticipation hey
thanks so much john
montez i super appreciate that i
appreciate any and all support that i
get
um and it really does help the channel
and your comments especially really help
the channel because sometimes it's uh
it's hard but i'm so grateful for what i
can do and i'm so grateful for
a community like you guys people like
you man
you guys make it all all worth it like
it's a dream come true for me i'm a nerd
who gets to talk about this stuff for a
living
like it's never been a better time to be
nerds right guys i mean like
i was picked on in school like not
nothing like you know stupid story
anything like that
but you know i because i liked all this
stuff but now it's like
you know we're cool so uh
east view east east view police is from
east view not west view okay
okay so yeah i'm gonna have to basically
watch this five times before i do my
breakdown and it's 4 am for me
so the town isn't real
she basically
took over
uh you got me i'm mephisto the 666
subcon
so the town isn't real hey what's up
it's jaguar how's it going
what's up malik hey cosmic water's not
mephisto you caught me
hey todd again with the donut thanks so
much man
super appreciate that
yeah vision could be her common sense i
think i think there's something like
that going on
t.j lewis echo samurai you've like
baffled me right there that's a good one
like
what if we're seeing how each character
died oof
i mean what uh what uh
oh
what an interesting thought you know
like
but my question would be why
i'm not saying you're wrong because i
think it makes a lot of sense especially
excuse me if everyone's dead
but why are we seeing that you know i
mean i just have a ton of questions
so
why does wanda suddenly see vision's
dead body
because i think
i think it is his dead body
again the post-credits scene
the post-credit scene that was supposed
to be for avengers in-game
was wanda seeing visions dead body and i
think she took it
and
i don't know she liked
brought it back to life so she could
like
i don't know guys it's so crazy and it's
like late so i gotta wrap my
head around it um
oh gosh
that's crazy man
all right grayson got it
man yeah doomsday nightmare also makes
sense you know i mean it could very well
be nightmare this is a night this
one is well uh
it's very clear
i like the nightmare ideas but it's very
clear
that this
is one has created some energy field you
can go in the energy field
you can be a part of this fake reality
um i don't know
if
i don't know if nightmares i don't know
if she's asleep inside of this thing
right
like that's my only thing like people
are walking around they're moving monica
rambo's interacting with her
i don't know if
i don't think she's asleep but but
but again yeah when i saw a vision i was
like whoa that's creepy and nightmare
didn't cross my mind
right so uh yes maria
rambo from what they said yes created
sword
oh is it that's pretty cool
shorty d17 it's the same office as uh
nick fury walks in and the captain
marvel suite
the wombat of infinite wisdom dang
well guys i have a lot to dissect right
now
i'm gonna go over this gonna do a
breakdown it's gonna take me
you know several several hours
so i'm going to dissect this thing look
for every easter egg i can come up with
every theory i can see what makes the
most sense
but uh this is awesome i love these live
chats uh i like talking to you guys so
like
hearing what everybody has to think of
like reacting together
especially because this one i saw the
first three episodes before they came
out i didn't see this one
they only sent us the first three so we
know
a bit now we know wanda's responsible
but clearly there's there's another
[Music]
being involved somehow and that's
because
agnes is not a part of sword and she's
not with wanda
yeah which is crazy
i think i think it i think it's out of
the harkness the grim reaper is involved
somehow
um and fisto
that's what i think you know but
i mean the next episode
hopefully we get like another wanda
perspective i mean we have to see like
the kids grow up in halloween episode
and all that stuff like that
so there's a lot to like really dissect
and look forward to for the ones coming
up
so there's sword
there's wanda and then there's
i got the harkness and whoever else is
behind that
so we'll see so
doctor strange i think is eventually
going to come in here
uh jack solavei um
theorists in this appreciate the
donation why don't you
uh dm me on my personal instagram it's
just cosmic warren
and we can talk them there um
appreciate the no-no just yeah shoot me
a dm on
cosmic war on instagram all right guys
i'm gonna go dissect this sucker
gonna spin my brain trying to think of a
bunch of different theories and we're
gonna try to figure it out because i
mean
dang yeah echo samurai i'm going to look
into that for sure appreciate that
uh tells people real people shane graham
thank you so much for the donation
telling people were real people
this was just an illusion i want to just
make them up so they can't
malfunction vision of babies probably
too then yeah no totally agree
um and going back to what somebody said
in the beginning
when monaco went into the energy field
she got different clothes but when she
came out she kept those clothes
so it does seem like you know what
happens in this thing kind of transfers
over
i don't know about the dead theory i
don't know if they're dead
because we have the grim reaper easter
egg right death
that you know there has to be something
there with that so man i don't i don't
know but i do think they're real people
and i think they're alive
so
six eighteen of six norm files of info
we haven't seen
i looked at that but i couldn't really
see it
yeah i'll have to look through that so
all right guys i
super appreciate everybody stopping by
tonight it was super awesome i love
these watch parties again
next thursday night going to be doing
the same thing another watch party
um i'm gonna do the best i can to break
down this trailer for you and come up
with what i think is
is going on so look out for that video
tomorrow well today
for i'm saying probably like five hours
six hours
we'll see how it is damper prince call
put school in the house what about hydra
um yeah dude i was born in pensacola i
was born a sacred heart hospital
um i think
hydra is just related to her past
they could be manipulating it somehow
but i think it's mostly related to her
past
so but all right guys going to crack of
this sucker
going to watch it a billion times frame
by frame watch it super slow
figure out what's going on and look for
my video in like five six hours
maybe around then so again thank you so
much
everybody for stopping by you guys are
awesome you're the reason i do all this
you're the reason i can do all this
and i super appreciate it so again sorry
for my setup
because i am helping my uncle rebuild
this house right now so i'm in arkansas
and out of my normal house
this is why everything is like this
sorry um
but